loin d'être qq cette boîte aux lettres
est une oeuvre d'art inspirées d'un nom
de famille des oeuvres de ce type il y
en a des centaines à saint-martin d'abba
tout a commencé en 1996 dans l'esprit
d'un homme désireux d'apporter une
identité culturelle à la connu dans
laquelle il venait de s'installer alors
cette boîte aux lettres et la boîte aux
lettres qui a précédé le fait de lancer
ce projet de création de du village des
boîtes aux lettres c'est celle d'un
ferronnier d'art copenhague à sa petite
sirène à bruxelles sont manneken pis et
saint-martin d'abba son aval monde la
mascotte du village des boîtes aux
lettres qui s'affiche officiellement
depuis 2001 le festival organisé chaque
année attire de nombreux visiteurs comme
edith elle est venue elle l'a vu elle a
été convaincue qu'à l'ue et d'états
saint michel
alors toi tu vas chercher tout repos
lieu bah ouais michel le papa des boîtes
aux lettres nous a présenté le sujet et
j'ai adhéré tout de suite j'ai eu un
coup de coeur et dès le lendemain j'ai
commencé à rechercher des boîtes aux
lettres autour de moi et j'ai imaginé
notre future boîte aux lettres ben c'est
des livres que j'ai que justin m'a
demandé de lui commander
donc ça va repartir pour le japon ça
voilà edit qui habitent dans une commune
voisine a donc rejoint les chasseurs de
boîte
ils sont quatre à sillonner tout le
département du loiret à la recherche de
création originale
à force de découvrir les boîtes aux
lettres un peu partout dans toutes les
communes du loiret on s'est dit mais
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
qu'est ce qu'on va en fait on va essayer
de les mettre en valeur mettre en valeur
les familles des gens qui font des
boîtes aux lettres comme ça et c'est
comme ça que petit à petit s'est imposée
l'idée de créer un conservatoire un
conservatoire qui s'appuie sur le
traditionnel concours de boîtes aux
lettres sur un livre en cours
d'élaboration et sur une carte
interactive disponible sur le net qui
recense à chaque nouvel objet repéré une
pierre en constante évolution comme l
idée de michel qui ne s'est encore pas
jusqu'où va le mener son nouveau projet
peut-être au-delà du département de la
région et qui sait de nos frontières